[Music]  et is taking you inside Peta Murgatroyd  and Maksim Chmerkovskiy zat nursery  bless the Dancing with the Stars couple  welcomed their first child son shy in  December and this is the room they  brought him home to celebrity nursery  designer Vanessa Antonelli put together  the room featuring lots of a dreamy  cream and glittery gold accents PETA  tell ZT the room fits in perfectly with  the rest of their home and is working  out great for her and shy quote between  nursing pumping and feeding I am loving  the rocking chair and ottoman it is such  a comfortable spot for both of us to  spend all those hours together and it's  beautiful to look at  [Music]  you